making America great again nine nine
nine nine nine nine nine percent I'm
Rita Hearst and I miss her alright how
many times have we heard the comparisons
from very much resembles the Nazi leader
Adolf Hitler Donald Trump to Adolf
Hitler Donald Trump is like Hitler it's
similar to a Nazi salute they're their
quotes from Hitler so do you still
support all these comparisons to Trump
it's like it bums me out any moment that
I have to call Trump out for being an
inheritor to Hitler I will last one of
course most recently from Jill Soloway
at the Emmys writer director for the
series transparent because
transgenderism as the cause du jour
right now and everything is transphobic
despite the fact that Donald Trump was
so welcoming to the trans community that
Caitlyn Jenner himself made Trump Tower
his location of choice to take a dump to
be fair Hitler did make exceptions for
Jews who had to pinch a loaf Megan thank
you he's a big softie at heart now
listen to compare your political
opposition to literally Hitler is simply
lazy but to do it in this election
Trump isn't even the right candidate to
pick
[Applause]
[Music]
Hillary Rodham Clinton has far more in
common with self-avowed leftist
socialist Hitler as I've outlined in
previous videos here and here and I've
actually gotten a lot of guff from
youtubers who don't argue the point
merely say what do you really think
Hitler was a leftist socialist yes yes
absolutely
just because you say it flippantly
doesn't make it any less true so we're
not just talking about rhetoric or
clickbait headlines but substantive
policy commonalities so for that between
Hitler and Hillary let's dive a little
deeper now aside from socialist actually
being the Nazi party's name the party
has far more in common with big
government Democrats of today than free
enterprise advocating conservatives
let's start off with economic policy
right off the bat fiscal policy Hitler
as left as could possibly be expressly
targeted wealth yes to start off with it
was Jewish wealth a lot of people try to
excuse this as nationalism versus
leftism because he would never do that
to the non-jewish German people except
he did the Nazi regime didn't have
enough to cover the tab for building up
their military omits World War two they
decided to hit most German groups with a
fifty percent surtax as well so on the
surface rhetorically that's very clearly
much more comparable to Hillary Clinton
we're going after where we think the
real money is as we say follow the money
and the tax system has been in my view
not effective in capturing money from
people who are very successful and we
need to do a better job and just like
Hitler didn't get enough money from the
Jews Hillary can't get enough money from
the wealthy so this happens solely
focusing on the racial identity politics
does not erase the overarching and
consistent far-left
economic policies instituted by Adolf
Hitler outside of taxes what else did he
do with his far left fiscal policy well
he suspended the gold standard he
increased government Prague
to a mammoth amount like instituting job
programs the Autobahn expanding credit
bulldozed many private companies on
prices and production decisions created
a national health care and unemployment
insurance program and eventually of
course ran huge deficits just how non
right-wing was this economic policy well
so much that Keynes himself praised the
Nazis economic program John Maynard
Keynes wrote the theory of output as a
whole which is what the following book
purports to provide is much more easily
adapted to the conditions of a
totalitarian state than is the theory of
production and distribution of a given
output produced under the conditions of
free competition and a large measure of
less a fad no I'm not saying Keynes was
a Nazi nor that Hillary Clinton was a
Nazi simply that your comparisons
between Trump and Hitler are asinine
let's move on to another point that
leftists ardently argue gun control
there's no way around it yes Hitler
enacted gun control yes he used the
registry to disarm Jews and yes he used
it to kill political dissidents in the
spirit of transparency let me provide
you with the argument that the left will
use against this fact the leftist
argument is written here as meanwhile
many more categories of people including
Nazi Party members were exempted from
gun ownership regulations altogether the
law did prohibit Jews and other
persecuted classes from owning guns but
this should not be an indictment of gun
control in general yes it should see
people try and argue well it wasn't
really gun control because the Nazis
were allowed to have guns it was only
the Jews so that's not real gun control
by the way it wasn't just the Jews it
was anybody who disagreed with Hitler
just so happens the Jews had more qualms
than most the references are available
at law doroth CARICOM even in arguing
against it the Left fails to see that
the back door in through gun control
allows any administration maybe not this
administration maybe not Hillary
Clinton's administration but the next
one to use it to selectively disarm
dissidents nobody isn't merely a passing
concept that needs to be protected for
generations to come compare those
policies with Hillary Clinton's view on
the Second Amendment if it is a
constitutional right than it like every
other constitutional right is
subject to reasonable regulation big
hail thunder thighs let's move on to
abortion it's no secret that Hillary
Clinton is a huge if not outright rotund
supporter of a woman's right to abort
her baby the unborn person doesn't have
constitutional rights
can you guess Hitler's view on abortion
yes here making yourself my needles
Nieto found in harvest of hate they may
use contraceptives the practice
abortions the more the better in view of
the large families of the native
population it could only suit us if
girls and women's there had as many
abortions as possible listen it's no
secret that eugenics were an integral
part of the Nazi regime and it's no
secret that they were integral in the
modern abortion movement as spearheaded
by Margaret Sanger it's so not debatable
hillary clinton was forced to
acknowledge it whilst giving Margaret
Sanger praise I admire Margaret Sanger
being a pioneer in trying to empower
women to have some control over their
bodies and I deplore statements that you
have referenced brings us to another
point the First Amendment freedom of
speech and freedom of the press no I'd
be lying if I said that Donald Trump's
rhetoric on libel laws and going after
journalists doesn't worry me he hasn't
quite outlined it as policy but that's a
fair criticism that I think one can make
but Hillary Clinton is every bit as bad
and then some I know I'll get crap for
this because many of you like to parrot
talking points and have no understanding
of the case Citizens United wasn't
answer to a very specific question it
was whether a movie created specifically
to be critical of then-senator Hillary
Clinton legally had the right to be
released on pay-per-view within 30 days
of a primary under the bipartisan
campaign finance reform Act of 2002 it
was banned the justices struck it down
ruling that the First Amendment yes
protects political speech to think that
citizens united is wrong is to say that
people when they become companies do not
have the right to political speech and
films like this could be outlawed that's
why Hillary Clinton is against citizens
united the film
was about her it was about her
corruption of course she's going to be
against it that's why Hillary Clinton
following super PACs pay millions of
dollars to police social media and fight
back on critics on Twitter and YouTube
yes really which brings us back to the
big picture policy-wise the idea of
valuing and prioritizing the individual
versus that of the state and listen I've
tried to support Donald Trump when I
think he's right and criticize him when
I think it's fair but the consistent
pattern of not only Donald Trump but the
Republican platform of less gun control
of less taxation of less control over
the economy is not indicative of a
fascist who wants to take over your
individual lives but Hillary Clinton
someone who personally and is running on
the platform of more gun control of
higher taxation of bigger regulation of
more intrusive government of giving them
more control over your lives again even
if it's not them who becomes tyrannical
you're opening the door and allowing the
next guy or woman or Z to be to what
Steven are you trying to say that Hitler
wasn't really right-wing and you would
have more in common with the left like
Hillary Clinton yes liberalism the tags
here but YouTube doesn't have a tag for
leftists sorry take it up with the D
monetize errs but if you liked this
video subscribe or click one of these
videos playing next to me one of them's
a mystery box Oh what is it what is it
is it Hitler stuff is it cat stuff maybe
it's more Crowder stuff nobody knows
you've got a decision to make